meet John a talented programmer who is
looking to start a company that used his
personally developed mobile application
to connect restaurants and customers for
booking and reservations
even though the app was ready John had
difficulty getting together a team for
his startup needing separate people for
sales marketing programming content
creation and customer support
hiring reliable Manpower while being
strict with his budget was getting
difficult
he reached out to his friend Ryan who
said John could start his company
without hiring any new people thanks to
just a single AI based tool John
couldn't believe it which led Ryan to
introduce chat gbt the Revolutionary AI
chatbot being developed by openai it is
a state-of-the-art natural language
processing or NLP model that uses a
neural network architecture to provide
responses
this means that the chat GPT bot can
answer questions without being
explicitly told what the answer is using
its own intellect unlike previous AI
chat Bots
so how does chat GPT help John in
filling out his team
regarding sales chat GPT can provide
full-fledged sales pitches based on the
correct prompts it can provide tips on
how to pitch your product businesses
removing the need for sales training
completely customized to your
requirements and your prompts if you
don't like some things about the
response you can ask for certain changes
and the chat bot will make sure they are
done when it comes to marketing chat EPT
can provide efficient marketing
strategies which can help new
entrepreneurs learn how to Market their
products to prospective clients it can
provide trending keywords that marketers
can use for SEO purposes while providing
ad copies for your website and blog
speaking of websites since John can do a
lot of the heavy lifting and programming
chat GPT can help proofread the code and
help out when looking for bugs to fix
apart from basic bug fixing it can also
provide sample code structures for
different programming languages allowing
John to focus more on improving core
functionality and workflow rather than
fixing basic code errors
websites and blogs content is very
helpful in gathering potential customer
leads
the Revolutionary bot can provide
full-length blog posts with near perfect
fast accuracy in seconds allowing
further customization like choosing the
length of the subject matter to the
complexity of language
for John's customer support the black
can draft complete customer service
emails based on the situation saving
time and resources
the tone of the message can be changed
to reflect the nature of the message
creating an efficient alternative for
call center professionals
John was left speechless seeing this
level of Versatility from chat GPT and
wanted to implement it right away
however Ryan made sure John knew about
some drawbacks of the chat bot before
getting started
since the bot is trained mostly on data
up to 2021 many of the newer events May
still need to be discovered by chat GPT
even basic stuff like asking about the
current date and time is beyond its
scope much like the limited
understanding of context despite
providing near lifelike solutions to
certain problems
even the accuracy of many responses can
be questioned since the AI model is
still learning and being developed there
is a section of the public that believes
the Revolutionary tool can one day
replace Google search but that day seems
far-fetched so far because of the
variety of issues people keep running
into and using chat GPT
so here's a question for you which of
the following tasks cannot be carried
out by chat GPT
one provide latest news
2. complex mathematical calculations
3. food recipes four none of the above
think about it and leave your answers in
the comments section and we will provide
the answer next week give the correct
answer along with your reasoning and
stand a chance to win an Amazon voucher
however chat GPT poses a lot of promise
for the future of AI from full-skilled
automated divisions and organizations to
serving as the perfect digital assistant
open AI is creating a bot for the future
aimed at solving the problems of today
with the tools of Tomorrow the ability
to carry out a myriad of tasks with
minimum Manpower will boost productivity
at organizations in every sector thanks
to the Revolutionary chat GPT so how do
you think chat GPT will benefit your
daily life are you looking forward to
using the bot regularly for work or
personal life let us know your thoughts
in the comments below
we hope you enjoyed this video if you
did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated here's your reminder to
subscribe to our Channel and click on
the Bell icon for more on the latest
Technologies and Trends thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn
[Music]